the destination national Toluca arranger
in integrand
necessarily not Java
[Music]
well it was painful in the beginning
like my back started to hurt but that's
what they really want they want to see
your reaction your emotion I guess you
know that's the way it's going to make a
difference
[Music]
I've visited a couple because I wanted
to go there but then you know once I
looked at what they do they basically
they switch you from one drug to another
so it's not really beneficial you know
you're still gonna be dependent but on
something else
methadone suboxone
[Music]
so I'm a child of neutrality mr. Gaddafi
known as abolish Ramallah you were
sketchy sketchy canister yeah smart
Pokemon you around it you always get
tempted because you already tried it you
already felt it so you know that lasts
your whole life so you gotta fight it
every day the one day at a time
[Music]